england began last week in philadelphia
mississippi
on monday he was convicted of organizing
the 1964 murders of three civil rights
workers
who traveled to the south that year to
register african-american voters
during the mississippi freedom summer
we'll show you now the sentence handed
down today
this is 15 minutes
let's see
good morning
the german the sentencing of echo ray
killing is set this morning for 10
o'clock
is there anything that i need to go into
before i go into the sentencing phase of
this crowd
those of you who've never been judged
do not understand the
problems that a sentencing judge has at
this stage of the trial
is so easy throughout the trial the case
to hear the evidence
and rule on matters of law but when it
comes to sentencing this
is a different thing i've been judged
for 26 years
and uh it's one of the most difficult
things you'll ever do
and in all the years that i've sent
persons
i've never really learned how to do it
cases are different the parties are
different the crimes are different
so many factors and matters that i must
take in consideration
i've never really learned how to do it i
just have
done what i thought was the best thing
to do
in keeping with the law my oath
my responsibility to my hope to the
people
and to the defendant that's before me
the echo ray killing
was indicted for the crime of murder for
the murder of three persons
for crime it occurred in june of 1964
41 years later we have this trial where
he
now is before the court
he being presented to the court on the
issue of whether or not he was guilty of
the crime
of murder the jury
in hearing all the evidence of that was
presented
the law that was uh available in the
for the case did not find echo-ray
killing guilty of murder but instead
found him guilty of the crime of
manslaughter
regarding counts one two and three
the manslaughter instruction was given
at the request of mr mark duncan and mr
jim
hood as a lesser included offense
and manslaughter is a lesser included
offense of the crime of murder
and upon a request by the prosecuting
attorneys in such a case
that is the law that the the instruction
should be given so it was given and the
jury
in making this decision having heard the
evidence
did not find mr killen guilty of murder
but found him guilty
of manslaughter
the jury deliberated on this issue for
some time
and if you question their decision
then you are voiding the belief
in the jury system
uh the persons who served on that jury
did not volunteer for that service they
were commanded by an order of the court
to be here
to serve as jurors they were silenced
here from the four count
corners of neshoba county and they
qualified as jurors
because i asked of them the questions i
was required by law to ask
and upon the completion of that
the 12 jurors who were selected
qualified as proper citizens of this
county
and legally competent serve as jurors
you also have to remember that the 12
jurors were chosen by these parties
they had preemptory challenges and they
did challenge
royals and the twelve who served was not
challenged by
either mr killing or by the state of
mississippi
but was seated and impaled and given an
oath to make a true verdict
upon the evidence in the law uh
regarding the case the state of
mississippi versus echo ray killing
now they must live with this decision
uh no doubt they have it they may be
subjected to some criticism
they may be subjected to some abuse and
some uh
ridicule yet you just have to remember
that they are citizens who were here to
perform an
unpleasant duty and they did so
and i respect those persons and you all
of you
who have are critical of the judgment of
the jury those of you who believe that
the jury should have found mr killing
not guilty
and those of you who believe that the
finding of
verdicts of manslaughter was wrong and
they should have found
the person's guilty of murder
you have to remember that no doubt and
there's no question about
these persons attempted to follow the
evidence to the best of their ability
they're not trained persons you know i
dare say that if they had been polled
there's not a single one of the twelve
who has ever before served
as a juror
i watched court tv
the other day and i saw where
the people of neshoba county and the
jury
and even the state of mississippi was
demeaned
because the verdict was manslaughter and
not that
of murder and that was wrong and that
was
again attacking the integrity of the
jury system
and certainly you must believe that
that's the one
thing that we must have is so that
innocent people
people who have no purpose in mind but
to be fair and impartial and make a
judgment upon evidence
and after all is said and done there's
not a single person in this courtroom
who drove here today fearful for their
life
or afraid that they would suffer some
physical harm
and the reason for that is because
someone in neshoba county
as jurors appeared here on other
criminal cases
and followed the law and enforced the
laws
so that all of you could have be
protected
you'll leave here today protected and
secure that you're not going to be
harmed
and it's because the laws have been
followed
and enforced by the people of neshoba
county
i have been the judge for 23 years
i've made a lot of decisions i've made a
lot of decisions that affected the lives
and liberty of persons
and that's my job and this morning just
a few moments ago in chambers there i
offered to the lawyers here
would you like to go in there now and
take a seat and make a judgment
on mr killing and what on the evidence
of this case
and what uh what should be the penalty
and there's not a taker of my offer
now you have to remember that
i have a job to do
and i have to pass upon a sentence to a
person who's 80 years old
a person who has suffered a serious
injury
a person that uh could receive the
maximum sentence of 60 years
there are those of you in the courtroom
who would say that
a percentage of 10 years is a life
sentence
there's those of you who sir are in the
courtroom no doubt
or of the opinion that echo ray killing
should be sir uh sentenced to serve 60
years
now if this case had occurred and there
was only one person
this is a homicide case where a per
three persons was killed the distinction
is that of murder and manslaughter
really and truly only in the eyes of
punishment
because the facts are more or less the
same
the difference is 20 years
of life imprisonment if there had only
been one person killed
and echo ray killing was sentenced to
serve 20 years
in 1964 i don't think there would be one
person
who would say that that was an excessive
sense
but now today 40 years later
when mr killing is 80 years old and we
would consider the fact that three
persons would
kill is 60 years in excessive sentence
now the law does not make a distinction
in in the crying uh the the
sentence should a person 20 years
old receive a more severe sentence
than a person 80 years old
if so why why should there be a
recognition of punishment does not the
law recognize
it does not recognize the distinction of
age
it does not say that a person who is 80
years old
should receive a lesser sentence than a
person who is 20 years old
and as i believe mr killing to have been
in the year of 1964
something like 62 years old
so i have made a decision and i know
that the decision of course of course
may be criticized because a lot of
people
really don't understand but if you give
it an understanding
that all we're trying to do is do what's
right under the law and the facts of the
case
so it's my responsibility to make that
decision and i have done it
and that because it's my job before i
announce
the sentence of mr killing i do want to
say
that i want to express my public opinion
and appreciation to law enforcement who
has provided
the security and has assisted the court
in handling this case my clerk
patty lee who's been most helpful my law
clerks
the attorneys in this case the for the
defense
and the state they've been courteous
they've been professional
and they perform their job
that correct killing come around bring
mr killing around from the bench
no one has talked to me attempting to
persuade me
of what sentence to pronounce because i
think that they
understand that i would not tolerate
that i'll not tolerate any person to
come to me
and offer that mr killing should be
placed on house arrest or should receive
60 years that's something that i've
heard the evidence of this case
and i'm just the kind of guy that'll
butt with my own head
and i take no pleasure at all in
pronouncing sons
the three gentleman who was killed
each life has value and each life
is equally as valuable as the other lie
and i have taken that into consideration
that there are three lives involved in
this case
and the three lives should absolutely
be respected and treated equally
therefore echo a killing and count one
it's the sentence of this court that you
serve 20 years
into custody the mississippi department
of
corrections
and count two it's a sense of this court
that you served 20 years
into custody the mississippi department
of corrections with this sentence to run
consecutive
to the centers pronounced upon you in
count one
in count three it's a sentence of this
court
that you serve 20 years in the custody
of the mississippi department of
corrections
with this sentence to run consecutive to
the sentences
pronounced upon you in counts one and
two
gentlemen do you have any comments now
as i've announced to you
monday of next week i'll hear any
emotions that you might have
uh those motions will be heard at nine
o'clock
mr killing you're submitted to the
custody sheriff
of the shoba camp
you